alors justement vous êtes reconnus comme
grand européen michel barnier mais vous
avez dit vouloir être utile à la france
et votre famille politique la droite les
républicains alors sous quelle forme
évidemment on parle de primaire est ce
que vous souhaitez plutôt vous imposer
comme candidat naturel
écoutez prenez les choses dans l'ordre
j'ai simplement d'une chose qui a
surpris peut-être créé une attente
quelques espoirs
j'ai dit que je reste un homme politique
je suis pas devenu super technocrates
bruxellois je n'ai jamais été je suis un
homme politique depuis très longtemps
est temps que je garde la même capacité
d'indignation ou d' enthousiasme la même
énergie ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
je vais mettre cette énergie au service
de mon pays en revenant maintenant plus
quotidiennement en france je suis très
heureux de retrouver les français qui
vont manquer mon pays et d'utiliser mon
énergie dans ce pays qui en a besoin
voilà ce que je peux dire aujourd'hui
nous verrons bien en tout cas c'est
c'est pas le moment de l'aventuré
individuelle aujourd'hui quand on voit
ce qui se passe dans le pays avec cette
crise franchement les français attendent
autre chose comme responsabilité d'homme
politique je sais le temps d'un treuil
collectif alors cela dit pour ce qui est
de votre de votre personnalité elle et
elle est bien cassée dans un dans un
sondage et la baie du 7 janvier
9e place 27% d'opinions favorables
d'ailleurs comme aviez bertrand et
devant valérie précresse pour ce qui est
des personnalités de la droite est ce
que ça vous encourage à vous revenez à
la même question
je suis heureux que l'action que j'ai pu
mener depuis beaucoup d'années à la fois
comme président d'un département j'ai
été très longtemps élu en savoie comme
membre du gouvernement ça a été mon
honneur comme commissaire européen
aujourd'hui comme négociateur que ce que
j'ai pu faire et la manière dont j'ai pu
le faire en regardant les gens dans les
yeux en étant sincère n'est en vrai en
évitant les polémiques inutiles
bon je crois que la politique ça
consiste à construire du progrès
collectif ils n'ont pas entretenir des
polémiques
donc j'ai envie de continuer à
construire du progrès pont pour mon pays
et pour pour ce continent est sûr que et
dans ce sondage qui est indicative comme
tous les sondages ça soit reconnue oui
votre retour sur la scène française
risque de faire peur à un certain
emmanuel
vous en avez conscience la question
franchement on n'est pas là ce pays a
besoin de beaucoup d'énergie de toutes
les énergies
j'ai des relations cordiales avec le
président de république j'appartiens à
une famille politique différente et il
le sait j'ai toujours essayé de nagy
retour un projet pour une certaine idée
de mon pays plutôt que contre et je
continuerai avoir cette attitude là
[Musique]